all right welcome everyone this is
Jeremy schiefling with Khan Academy I am
so thrilled to welcome you back for
round two of our Ai and education
webinar Series this summer I know that
this summer time is your time and so I
apologize for intruding upon it but I'm
so thrilled that you decide to join us
because we have a rock star panel here
we have a couple of incredible Educators
from across the universe we've got Emily
and Kelly coming to you from the Khan
World School in partnership with ASU
they're sweating it out right now down
in Phoenix as you probably heard about
we have Madeline coming from the School
City of Hobart in Indiana one of our
amazing Khan Academy districts partners
and one of the Pioneers in using condigo
in the classroom and then we have Malia
from our OG con lab school right here in
Mountain View California
um so we have lots of different
perspectives represented and then of
course a man who needs no deduction Sal
Khan himself is on the line ladies and
gentlemen here to tell you about uh
conmigo and what the future looks like
in the space now that being said before
we dive in we want to get to know you a
little bit better so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to launch a poll right
now and I'd love to hear from you where
are you coming from occupationally are
you a classroom teacher a counselor an
instructional coach let us know right in
the chat number two let us know the
kinds of students you serve are you on
the older end of the spectrum like so
many of the Educators here or maybe your
Early Childhood I was a former
kindergarten teacher I'd love to hear
from that perspective as well and then
finally let us know your primary subject
area we definitely have a lot of really
strong Humanities folks but Sal himself
has volunteered to speak directly to the
math and science angles if you're
curious as well
so with about five seconds left five
four three two and one we'll end the
poll
and let's share these results out so as
you can see a ton of classroom teachers
which is awesome but also some admins
instructional coaches Librarians
curriculum developers love to see that
we have a pretty even mix across
elementary middle and high with a little
sort of preference for the latter but
even some folks all the way to college
and adult education which is fantastic
and then finally as you might expect
we've got a strong showing from the math
Educators out there but lots of great
folks and science Ela social studies and
Beyond
so with that said quick ground rules
before we Dive In this session is going
to be recorded and that's the number one
question that everyone has asked in
every webinar ever since the pandemic
and yes you will absolutely get a copy
sent directly to your email afterwards
however what's more because you joined
live and shared some of your Summertime
with us you're going to receive a free
professional development certificate
mailed to you right after the session
and be entered into a drawing for 12
free months of conmigo our brand new AI
guide
and to make the most of the session
because you are here live what we would
love for you to do more than anything
else is come to the Q a and do two
things number one Whatever questions you
have about Ai and education no matter
how big no matter how small no matter
how spicy feel free to put those in
right now and throughout the session and
then number two just as importantly
support your fellow Educators by
upvoting the ones that you're excited
about for anyone who came to our last
session you know that we took those
primarily in the order of upvotes and so
if you've got big juicy questions feel
free to give that that big plus sign we
will be sure to take those
so with all of that said let's start
with a question that so many people
asked in our pre-survey which is how do
you believe AI is going to actually
impact education so I know this is a
little bit crystal ball like in the
sense that we're thinking about where
things are headed versus think where
things are here in the summer of 2023
but for our panelists if you want to
take that question if you're excited to
dive into it just go ahead and raise
your hand and I will call on you to take
it and Sal it sounds like you might have
something you want to share right off
the top
oh sure and you know obviously none of
us have a crystal ball or could predict
the future but in some ways I view you
know my answer to that question is is
also the answer how I thought about
edtech even pre-generative AI which is
uh it's it's never about somehow
um
it's never about the technology it's
really about what the pedagogical goals
that we all want to do and I think
for time immemorial well before AI well
before uh the internet and computers
all Educators have always recognized
that the gold standard is some form of
differentiation there's a lot of
literature and honestly Common Sense
behind Mastery learning if a student
hasn't fully mastered a concept they
should always have the opportunity to
get their you know their understanding
of decimals from an 80 to 95 because if
they don't they're really going to
struggle with algebra when those
equations involve decimals and this is
true and pretty much every every subject
area so and one of the ways that that
would have been addressed say 50 years
ago is by having a better student
teacher ratios having a teaching
assistants in the room a middle class
upper middle class affluent families can
afford Tutors or many maybe sometimes
the parents will do the tutoring
themselves to provide that level of
personalization obviously you know I'm a
fan of the more resources we can throw
at the students being able to reach
their potential the better but there are
some in our control there's some that
aren't in our control we can't control
the student teacher ratio we can't
control
whether or not a student has tutoring at
home or whether there's a teaching
assistant in the class if there is all
of those things awesome so our view at
Khan Academy has always been how can we
use technology to at least start to
approximate some of those things that's
where classic con let's call it has been
let's give people practice at their own
time space initially in math and science
and then we've also started moving the
humanities Ela is not not that far away
where someone can learn at their own
time Pace very deep item Banks so that
they haven't learned it they can keep
practicing it they're spaced reputation
Spiral Review to make sure that they've
really gotten to proficiency and
mastering things there's on-demand video
and hints so that people can get unstuck
hopefully and that all of that gets
reported to the teacher so that they can
get better information on how they can
work with their students they don't have
to give a one-size-fits-all for every
student that hey those 10 students have
got it they can keep working these 10
students could use a a more focused
intervention and then after I'm done
with those 10 these five over here could
use a different Focus intervention so
that's that's kind of been the vision
and
um I think generative AI just takes that
to another level uh where uh now if a
student has you know the videos aren't
doing enough for the student the
exercise hints aren't doing it the
Articles they can ask questions
sometimes questions they would have been
afraid to ask teachers I get that answer
but in many cases they might have been
willing to ask the teacher But the
teacher can't go to 30 kids who are all
asking different questions
um
the generative AI can act more like a
teaching assistant you know the best
that edtech could do pre-generative AI
is give you all these dashboards that
look like spreadsheets and you have to
kind of like okay which kids are
struggling and which kids are and now um
you know we're investing in modalities
where you can have a conversation with
the data so to speak and um we think
that'll make it much much easier for
teachers and then there's a whole series
of workflows which we hadn't thought
about before because we didn't think it
was possible but now you can where a
teacher spend a ton of time doing things
like writing lesson plans grading papers
creating rubrics
progress reports and those are all areas
where we think generative AI could you
know substantially safe
um teachers time so long answer all my
answers aren't going to be this long but
uh I you know I'm hoping in five years
we're in a world where students are
feeling much more supported teachers are
feeling much more supported they have
much more time and energy for themselves
so they don't burn out and more time and
energy to do kind of the things why I
think most most teachers went into the
profession kind of more time for those
really amazing engaging moments with
with students I'll say one last thing is
uh you know I also think the AI being
able to have that Loop between
assignment rubric lesson creation
supporting students that say they work
on an essay and then being able to
report back to a teacher not only is
that going to be really supportive of
all of the parties in that mix but I
actually think it can address like the
chat GPT cheating issue where if you
assign an essay and a student
um
and a student let's see the ring on
conmigo and they're doing brainstorming
with the AI the ai's not doing it for
them but it's riffing with them it's
acting as a a guide uh then the AI can
report back to the teacher say yes we
spend this much time we did this we
changed our thesis but eventually got
there and based on the rubric I'd give
it an initial 85 what do you think
teacher you could feel confident that
that student didn't cheat but if a
student goes to chat gbt has that essay
generated and just copies and pastes
that into conmigo then conmigo itself
will say hey this looks fishy there's no
there's no process here and I think you
know honestly because of bandwidth
issues it was already very expensive and
time consuming to grade 30 papers on the
same topic and for middle school
students so you definitely never had
time to really go into the process but
now we can hopefully streamline that
love that thank you for starting us off
Sal let's go next to Emily over at the
con World School Emily what's your take
on where this whole education and AI
world is headed
cell offered a lot of
those but definitely see it as a
tutoring option to help get at students
more individually on an individual level
I'm an English teacher by trade and so
I'm just always thinking about well if
they want to use AI as a way to generate
a first draft I think the power of
writing comes in revision anyway and so
if they're going to learn how to revise
how to make ideas better how to get rid
of very formulaic typewriting
um that can be very helpful at the high
school level
and if they're using it as a tool and
not as a method of this is doing my work
for me but teaching them those subtle
distinctions about how we use tools to
help us but we are the ones that can
then flesh that out and really create
something better and stronger and so I
think in that way it's very helpful and
in the same way that I'll also mentioned
that it becomes a way to kind of create
time
there are shortcuts that are helpful for
teachers you don't always have to write
the same email or you don't always have
to you've you've created a tool that
also can save you time
um but I also think it can be like that
tutor but the power of a teacher really
comes in the relationship and that AI
will never circumvent a relationship
right like that will always be there for
a teacher that will always be something
that in those moments when you can get
at that individual student which maybe
the AI will help you to have more of
those individual moments because then
those students can be working at a
computer and then you can use that time
to pull kids aside and to have those
one-on-one interactions that are
especially valuable and that will create
those moments those really strong
teachable moments
um so that's my hope I am taking a very
positive and optimistic view of what AI
can do for educators I certainly hope
that it doesn't remove edge caters from
the field because education is such a
powerful tool but then again we have a
teacher crisis at least in Arizona where
I live and so maybe there is more need
for that if we're not able to recruit
teachers but that kind of breaks my
heart at the same time so those are some
of my thoughts as I think about the
power and future of AI
wow and then um let's go to Madeline as
for the last sort of answer on this one
we'll come to Malia for the next
question because that's juicy as well
Madeline any thoughts here absolutely uh
so for just a little bit of context
um I am an English teacher uh and the
English department chair at Hobart High
School and we do a lot of partnership
with Early College Programs so we have a
lot of students who are Juniors
sophomores who are taking college level
classes that's amazing for them and
wonderful for them but
um we're in a very blue-collar town I
have a lot of first generation college
students and a lot of kids who have to
work to help their parents pay the rent
or the mortgage and
um they have practice for their multiple
Sports on top of that because the
competition among students to be able to
get into colleges as the cost is getting
higher and higher it's just getting all
the more expensive for them and there's
so much fear about not being able to be
enough
so one of the areas that I think hasn't
been touched on a lot
um in this conversation so far has been
on how is it going to help our students
um it kind of I guess I am building off
of what Sal said a little bit in terms
of leveling the playing field I was
looking over my students conmigo chat
history and I was watching the different
time frames in which they were logging
in and using it and many of them were
using it after I would have gone to bed
right or I would not be available for my
students and I used to feel this
paranoia about needing to check my email
all the time in my off hours just to
make sure that if my kids had a question
you know God forbid it was the night
before the essay was due but let's all
be real we know our kids we know that
they're going to do that
um but when I'm not reachable I want to
know that they have the ability to get
their needs met
so this is a great way to be able to do
that
yeah I think that's a great call of that
I'm like I think even the world's
greatest educator can't be by their
student size at every single moment nor
should we expect them to and so to have
that resource there in that moment when
they need it that's pretty powerful okay
speaking of the power of
um Ai and then also a little bit of the
dark side I've got to tell you it is
overwhelming in the Q a the top two
questions are from Wendy how do students
use a high without cheating and from
Erica how best can we detect students
using AI inappropriately and then handle
those situations
so for our Gus panel I know we all have
different experiences with cheating or
with trying to prevent that thoughts
about how students can grab or teachers
can grapple with this reality
and let's go to matalix I know Madeline
you've seen this quite a bit you
probably have some strong thoughts here
I have yeah so when we were even when we
were doing our beta test with Khan Migo
actually I um I did run into this issue
a little bit where you know we'd had
conversations about responsible use with
our students
and they didn't always want to follow
those parameters I think the reality
that we have to face with AI is it's a
crisis that it crisis that is not
entirely unfamiliar to us right we went
through this same thing when Google came
out in the field of Education people
just concluded like oh God no kid is
ever going to have to memorize anything
anymore and what did we have to do we
had to change the way that we assigned
content right to focus Less on rote
memorization and I think we're going to
see that same kind of shift here so one
thing that my district has done um just
for context I've been working with my
superintendent a lot and kind of been
spearheading our AI initiative in our
district
um I'm going to share my screen really
quick uh let's see
I want to share this okay so one thing
that our district built to help with
this issue is we built a rubric it was
based off of Matt Miller and his um AI
for educators book
um our mascot is the bricky I know that
won't make sense to a lot of you but
just go with me on this so we have a
rubric that we've made where we have
human generated at the bottom and AI
generated at the top and we have
descriptors in here for the level to
which
AI would be allowed to be used so when
each assignment would be given we would
be able to say okay kids this is the
level
of comfort level we have with you using
AI versus human generated content so you
know for instance here the one that I'm
on right now it talks about using AI to
help with brainstorming but then having
to go find sources on their own that
address that same subject and through
having access to chat history with
conmigo that will help a lot in terms of
mitigating those concerns
awesome I love that and now that I will
follow up with you afterwards and see if
we can borrow that to share with others
so that everyone's taking screenshots as
you were sharing that that was so cool
love it
um let's go next to Kelly Kelly what's
your take on this question yeah hi
everyone
um you know I think I think this is you
know this question always comes up and I
think uh personally you know we keep
doing the same things we always do to
prevent cheating regardless of the
source you know kids are going to cheat
if they're gonna cheat they're going to
find a way
um
you know I think you know and I love
what Madeleine just shared
um because part of you know what I think
is also it's educating everyone around
the student too uh making sure everyone
on you know your teaching team knows how
to use these tools
um and knows about these options parents
making sure parents know you know
perhaps having some informative nights
and materials that can go out to
families so they know how to work with
their children on
um some of these platforms
um so you know I think it's just new and
I think it you know um you do the same
thing we always do like uh designing
assignments to circumvent cheating as
well you know
um
you know making sure there's steps in
the process that they have to go through
that in the end
um you know results in their own
thinking there too
um and I also love you know the thing
about something like conmigo that I like
is that back-end data too so it's not
um you know if you're promoting the use
of it teaching them how to use it
including it in the assignment perhaps
we can be
um more likely to
um
you know not control it necessarily but
be able to see later in that data how
students are using it too so I think
it's all those things combined with what
we're already doing and right now
um the biggest part of it is just making
sure educating
um all of our staff and families you
know and parents and people working with
students on how to use it properly
that's awesome and then finally let's go
to cell so I'd love for you to speak to
this and then I would love to dive into
math next because I know that's a Hot
Topic as well yeah I'll just say a
little bit from the technology side of
things you know anyone who's telling you
and I know there's a lot of folks out
there who are claiming that they're
creating
um generative AI writing detectors the
same way that you have plagiarism
detectors anyone who says that to you is
selling you snake oil
um so be very suspicious of anything
else that comes out of that person's
mouth uh you know there are ways that
you might be able to do it in very basic
ways that might detect it in some cases
but we know our students your students
um it's it's going to be very easy to
circumvent that and it's I think we
should all operate from the assumption
that it's essentially undetectable
um I think that's the only safe
assumption so
the option uh that we all have is you
know the the non-tech options are you
know hopefully some type of an honor
code could be used in certain cases in
certain cases I'm sure many of y'all
would probably roll your eyes and say
nope I think it's too tempting when you
have something that can write an essay
so easily for you
um and there's a lot of gray area around
like how much help is too much help the
other option is obviously just do more
in class you're not obviously be able to
do like very ambitious projects in class
but you'll be able to maybe do some more
of that the other extreme is have more
ambitious projects and say yeah use
whatever you're going to use I don't
think that's appropriate for like kids
who are learning to write that might be
inappropriate at like
late high school or college where they
already know how to write and you're
making a business or something like that
so I don't think that's a viable option
I think I think the reality is if if we
want which I want and I think most of
y'all want if we want kids to continue
to do the types of research papers term
papers that all of us grew up with
because it did help us think it did help
us learn to write and even just to
project manage ourselves and to regulate
ourselves and plan something over you
know on our own
um I think it's going to have to be in a
safe environment where you can where you
can keep track of the process
um and this is what we're trying to do
at conmigo where the teacher can assign
the assignment through the AI and then
the and the teacher could decide how
much help or no help the AI should do
but then the student
um has essentially has to do the paper
in that type of an environment so that
essentially there's an audit trail of
their work and we can see oh it took
them this many hours and this is you
know this was V1 and after for one hour
this is V2 after two hours and I think
if students know that there's that audit
Trail because is much harder for them to
just go to chat GPT and generate
something and copy and paste it
very cool okay so now to switch from
this idea of how do we deal with the
realities of students in the classroom
to the realities of math education I
think this is the perfect question for
Sal Peter says my interest is math I
watched the last Khan Migo presentation
and was disappointed that use and math
was not covered and that's totally on me
Peter
um definitely I have a little bias
towards the humanities but I'm really
excited to remediate that today because
Sal of course got to start with Khan
Academy as a math tutor to his own
cousin so what Peter wants to know Sal
is what are the use cases for applying
conmigo as a math tutor we know that
these AI tools are so great with verbal
skills so great with writing what about
the math context what should Peter know
yeah and and in all fairness you know
this is still early days where we're
trying to put a lot of stuff out there
and learn what's working and better or
worse uh you know the core idea behind
Khan Academy that and now we have
actually a ton of efficacy data behind
it you're gonna and everyone here is
gonna hear more about it but we there's
50 plus efficacy studies on Khan Academy
before generative Ai and it's all around
if students are able to put in you know
the threshold disability studies 18
hours a year it amounts to about 30 to
60 Minutes a week uh and they're able to
do personalized practice and and
different teachers have implemented
different ways but the bottom line if
they're able to get those two to three
20-minute sessions a week for most of
the school year these kids are
dramatically accelerating they're
accelerating depending on the study and
the grade level 30 40 50 60
um and so the key question for us is
okay we have these studies
how do we get more kids to engage and to
feel progress at that I think every all
Educators know regardless motivation and
engagement is often the key
um even 30 years ago if you're
sufficiently motivated you could power
through a textbook if you really had to
but most people didn't weren't that
motivated
um and so you know on the Khan Academy
side that's why we've always wanted to
you know provide supports like videos et
cetera Etc I think
generative Ai and what we're trying to
do with conmigo we're seeing as another
powerful support
um I'm curious well at places like kws
we do have math teacher I know they're
not here today who've been using I'll
tell you what I've been hearing that it
has been able to unblock students where
they might have might have been blocked
before sometimes it's a block of
literally they're confused they've
watched the video it still doesn't make
sense to them they've read the article
they've looked at the hints it still
doesn't make sense to them so that helps
to have that gender gen Ai and just so
you all know you know we've done a lot
above and beyond the core gpt4 model and
you know Chad GPT uses gpg 3.5 or at
least the free version does but even
gpt4 which is dramatically better we've
done a lot of work to make it a much
much better in math
um and so we've definitely already heard
feedback in the first three months the
last three months of last school year
when we were piloting it that it is
helping
um students get their questions answered
in the moment uh oftentimes on exactly
that question that they're struggling
with or that concept sometimes it's a
motivational block like why do I need to
learn to learn this the famous question
the AI can can help out with things like
that
um
and and so those are I think the two
clear math use cases and then beyond
that we do have a general
um tutor me in stem or math type of
subjects where if a student just has any
broad question and I could imagine and
this is kind of something we threw out
there's a it's a new scope for Khan
Academy which is a you know if they're
working on a particular exercise on Khan
Academy or watching a video and they're
confused kanmigo can show up during
those sessions and and it has the
context of the video so you could say I
don't understand what Sal meant at this
moment and it can answer that or wait
this question I don't understand what
this question is asking for it can do
that
um the the the the general tutor one we
we could imagine that being used when
you're even doing your non-con Academy
work when uh you know maybe students are
in a project and if they're confused
about something maybe even during a
lecture if they're confused about
something right in that moment they can
get
um get an answer to it uh we we
obviously haven't had time to do rich
efficacy studies yet we have done some
pretty robust user research to at least
make sure that it's not doing harm so
far the initial indications are it's not
doing harm I think there are a little
bit of classroom management issues
sometimes because there's so much that
you can do with the AI that you know
okay don't talk to Abraham Lincoln right
now we have to work on our math like so
we're we're thinking through with
Educators on how we can we can we can we
can control that a little bit better
um but and we have some early
indications that it is indeed helping
kids be more engaged in their at least
in their Khan Academy core work and be
less unblocked but that's still a very
very preliminary news
very cool and then let's go next to
Malia Malia
I wanted to um focus on something Sal
said right there about students being
able to kind of like ask in the moment
like even if they're listening to a
lecture or even in like a live class
session just to kind of share an
antidote from from one of my classes
um this past term we were talking about
the founding fathers and we were the
students were reading a book that was
talking aloud about Ben Franklin and the
book was also talking a lot about his
sister Jane right and the book was
talking about how Ben kind of went from
regs to riches and Jane went from brags
to rags right and one of my students had
the question is this author biased right
okay so I want them to discuss that baby
that's a good one right I don't want to
like show my hand so I said why don't
why don't we ask Contigo right and so we
sat around and we talked about all right
how would we prompt this right how are
we going to get the information that we
want and Khan Migo was able to play with
it and it knew exactly the passage we
were talking about and then it gave an
answer about like this is the difference
between bias and perspective and all
historians have a perspective and like
what do you think right so that was an
opportunity for me to decenter myself
and let them have the conversation that
they were organically having
um and so I think that's like a good
kind of like in the moment and then
again that modeling of how do we get the
types of responses
um that we want out of this fun tool
very cool and then one last thought here
uh Madeline give us your take and then
we're going to go to a live caller if
you will so get ready
uh I I saw someone in the chat also
asking like when is science going to
come into the equation as well so I
wanted to
um bring something up that I know had
been helpful for a science teacher who
piloted conmigo in my building she and
her students really appreciated the fact
that Khan Migo is great at giving
analogies for particular Concepts
involving like the sciences and
involving you know history
um so you know one of the things that
immediately comes to mind for me is the
cell wall right I was really bad at
biology when I was in high school and I
didn't have a resource like this so I
went into conmigo and I asked for some
analogies for the actual you know
term make it make sense to me and it was
able to give me like five or six
different analogies that made that
concept make more sense and I think the
final one that it came up with was like
Captain America's shield and I love that
so you know I was immediately picturing
an activity where you could take your
vocab list of scientific terms and have
conmigo give a bunch of analogies that
would help it stick with your kids
better
um so that's a great way that it would
be able to be more than just an answer
machine it's a way to cement knowledge
for them
you know for those who don't know my
process when I make say science videos
some of them I have the intuition but a
lot of it I you know I I spent a lot of
time researching and I don't even want
to make a video until I feel like I I
really have a conceptual understanding
of of this thing I I've been using
conmigo myself uh you know that I a
couple of a couple of months ago I I was
always curious about you know why does
Supernova you know if you're out of fuel
in the star why doesn't it just collapse
why does it eject material uh
conceptually why does it do that and I
went to conmigo tutor me and stem and I
mean it was beautiful it said well do
you have any theories why it does that
and I was like oh you're asking me and
then I was like well huh you know what
it made me think and I'm like well I
don't know is it like a rebound is it
like you know and then they're like yeah
you're economy was like yeah you're on
the right track because the collapse is
there's a lot of pressure and it it's so
dramatic like you know have you ever
seen a some anything dropped from a high
height that doesn't bounce like I'm like
oh good point and like so it's yes it's
that then the bounce ejects some of the
stuff on the app and I never understood
that and this is you know this is
something I've always been interested in
I've even asked experts and they never
quite gave to him and or something they
gave me an explanation without making me
think think it through myself so yeah I
I actually think science is one of the
air because so much of science if we
want and I think we all want the kids to
go beyond memorizing the formulas or
memorizing the terms
um so much of science is making sure you
understand it conceptually and you know
we've gone to Great pains over the years
at Khan Academy to hopefully do that
through videos and articles but you know
different metaphors different
visualizations are going to connect for
different folks and I think this is
where it's really powerful
love that definitely so much creativity
baked in here
um let's do speaking of creativity let's
do something a little crazy we never
actually tried here at Khan Academy
before let's do some live call in and I
know uh live talk radio and edtech don't
always go together let's give it a shot
in the interest of innovation so Sandia
I know you've had your hand up for a
while thank you for your patience I'll
give you the chance to unmute your line
feel free to come on Sandy if you can
ask your question I'm so excited I've
never done this before either thank you
for um giving me this opportunity so I
I'm a math teacher I teach seventh grade
math and I went back this year up after
13 years
um at the math teacher quit in the
middle of the year at my daughter's
school and they asked me to fill in so
I'm my learning curve is extremely steep
coming back after 13 years and then with
all these tools and I've spent the whole
summer studying IAI and I was looking at
the question that we had asked in um the
conmigo about the Frac the help with
multiplying two fractions and the
response that came back was basically
multiply the numerator and the
denominator is AI or conmigo able to go
into more I think uh Sal you were
talking about conceptual understanding
that well why are we multiplying the
numerator and denominator are they just
going to get this the steps
great question simple answer is it
should be able to do that like it it
like we could even demo it right now
live uh I would say like why why do you
multiply the number and denominator can
you explain that I don't know yeah
absolutely you want to see what it does
Jeremy like for example um this year I
was teaching the kids like why do we
when we divide decimals why do we flip
it and multiply and the reality is you
don't have to right
all the kids like seriously you don't
have to I'm like it's to make your life
simpler that's why you do it you know
and I just don't I I want as we're
building thinking classrooms that's
really what we need to do as teach the
children how to think and if they don't
understand why they're doing the steps
even with AI it's not going to help them
become thinkers
yeah and I like the way to sort of
conmigo again reframed it through the
kids lens of not we just do it because
that's the way we've always done it but
it sort of puts it in this sort of pizza
frame if you will okay yeah I think of
being more effective yeah and you know
the one you just gave it Jeremy like we
didn't give it the context of the month
that's right
why do yeah we probably should ask when
we multiply fractions why do we multiply
numerators and Dot denominators uh yeah
clear clear clear the chat and then ask
it it'll probably give it when we
multiply
and this is a tip because when people
are asking like what's the best way to
use Ai and one thing that's for both for
your students and for your own use
whether you use conmigo or chat GPT or
whatever always think about that sort of
classic idea of garbage in garbage out
if you just ask something really generic
like how do you do this thing it may not
have enough context to go on but if you
explain what's going on what you're
trying to achieve it can be a lot more
effective So when you say when we
multiply fractions
why do we multiply
the numerator and denominator
are the numerators and denominators
listen imagine you have half a pizza and
you want to share it with a friend how
much does each Pizza get and yeah you
could you know you could say let's go
forth that's right let's try it forth
and this is great this is live TV
everyone this is not this has not been
planned
Sandia can you confirm that we were
meeting for the first time right now
yeah we are meeting for the first time
and I'm loving this because I love how
it's going back and saying how much like
asking the question back to that
students
yeah so I mean you know we could we
could keep going with this but yes it it
is actually I've actually the places
where generative hay historically
struggles the most is actually on just
doing the math and we've gone through
great pains to make that a lot better
than you would get it yeah before but on
the conceptual it's quite strong which
is still kind of uh amazing to me
so how do we use conmigo we have to get
a permission I'm assuming through our
I.T department or um at school or can I
just use it on my own or how does that
generally work
Jeremy and I are working very hard to
make that answer simpler over time
um so so unfortunately it's a little bit
complicated right now there's a couple
of ways there's going to be a a group of
districts so there's ways to go through
the district uh that we're talking to
school districts for this coming back to
school already there's also going to be
ways or there are there is a way that a
parent or teacher can sign up for an
individual account
um and Jeremy knows more about that I
will say and this is you know our
mission as a non-profit is free
world-class education for anyone
anywhere and obviously it always costs
money to build Khan Academy our budgets
about 70 million a year but the reason
why we've been able to you know it's
funded with philanthropy primarily and
then the marginal cost the incremental
cost of serving up the the pages or the
videos it's it's low enough that we can
do it for free for the most part
generative AI like every one of those
interactions that we just did was
literally going to like hundreds if not
thousands of like state of the art like
um Nvidia chips and so we get charged a
lot right now and so we are essentially
just charging folks for that cost so
it's passing through us to essentially
go to folks like openai and Microsoft
and Nvidia so that we can do it uh so uh
you know that's currently it's cost
about nine dollars a month
um is is where we are so and there's
different permutations but but that's
that's where it is today but we're
working pretty hard to see if we can get
the cost down and if we can um make it
easier for people to just sign up and
sign up their students
cool great question Sandia you have
restored our faith
what would you recommend because Jeremy
Beyond running awesome webinars like
this is also in charge of trying to get
what we call Grassroots users like so
people who aren't doing it through the
district to how they use Khan Academy
and conmigo in particular what is the
easiest way that you would say if a
teacher wants to
use it
Jeremy oh sorry my apologies yeah so the
link that I shared in the chat is the
easiest way to get access and similar to
like Netflix or something like that you
know you just sort of sign up that being
said as Sal mentioned we're always
trying to find ways to make it even more
affordable more accessible so look for
developments with that in the near
future and I will just say I didn't know
if that was a question was for Sandia
Sandia if you have ideas for how we can
get into more teachers hands more
parents hands please let me know when I
send you that PD certificate at the end
and I'll be putting a gold star on it
because you rock this on yes we'll do
we'll do and I'm wondering just sorry I
don't want to monopolize but one more
question because my daughter and my
school we've required kids to do Khan
Academy all summer to close the gap and
my daughter had 133 assignments to do
um is there do you see the future of
like when they're watching the videos or
doing their practice questions ended up
being like a
um like a collaboration with conmigo
where if they're stuck on that practice
question and can be more interactive
with whatever's what they're learning in
their skill based learning videos and
practice yeah that's already I mean does
the larger group that already exist when
kind of people gets turned on anytime
someone's doing anything on Khan Academy
conmigo can assist them answer questions
quiz them about it connect it to other
things oh that's awesome
thank you yeah kamigo will always be
that sort of guide on the side as we say
yeah watch that video on intro to
fractions
yeah
and
ask a question
oh you're in teacher mode right now
that's why it's saying write a lesson
plan things like that I mean you could
say you know write a poem about this
video
right
this is a it's actually a pretty good
summary when it does a poem
a square a rectangle and a pie all cut
up oh oh my oh wait I missed that as you
scroll up a little bit Jeremy
oh whoops all right so yeah definitely
lots of use cases
lots of use cases from the
um sort of teacher dashboard all the way
to the student experience
um Sonia you've been amazing thank you
so much thank you lots more of these but
for now let me actually go to a question
that's been waiting very patiently in
the wings in the Q a and actually speaks
to sort of two different variants here
first Scott says the internet enabled
data retrieval online tools enabled
self-learning AI enhances both and
brings new capabilities given all this
how much class time should teachers
spend demonstrating the best and most
ethical practices when you use these
resources
so in other words to We be really diving
deep here or just providing some general
guidelines and then Laura asks a
complimentary question which is how can
I teach my ninth graders how to use AI
effectively so we've kind of gone past
that plagiarism and cheating issue to
okay this is the reality of 2023 how do
we make the most of it any thoughts from
our amazing panelists let's go to Malia
the number one thing that I've stressed
in the classroom is that this is an
opportunity for us to all learn together
right like this just came out it's new
to all of us it's new to you it's new to
me and so being curious and like being a
role model for them saying like I'm
trying to figure out how to use it
ethically I'm trying to figure out how
to use it creatively like it's a tool to
like do the thing with our students
which I which I think is powerful and to
say to them you know as I have before
sometimes I'll say like well this is how
I'm prompting it how are you prompting
it right and to let their voices feel
empowered
let's go to Madeline
so kind of two things in response to
that on the um responsible use front um
this is exactly what I was just talking
about uh earlier today I was with our
students who are getting trained as
Writing Center tutors and I had a lot of
them as students last year and one of
them got pretty vulnerable and she said
Miss March I was so scared to use AI
because I didn't want to be doing
something wrong and I think what we
really need to internalize is because
the primary discourse right now is chat
GPT is an answer machine chat GPT is you
know causing a cheating outbreak there
are a lot of kids who are genuinely
fearful that by using it they're doing
something wrong so by giving them that
kind of rubric like the one that I
showed you where you know we're setting
the tone of hey this is what we're
permitting and giving them the chance to
play with it that's how you switch the
narrative is through giving them that
exposure and through giving them that
opportunity to try
um and then that's how they're going to
get more comfortable and also get better
at asking it the right questions
um the other thing that I brought up to
them is we would be doing a disservice
to them if we didn't give them that
exposure right because the world that
they're going into is going to be
increasingly
AI based or AI integrated and so if we
continued to Shield them entirely from
it would be causing a problem I think
having those structured activities where
they can play but play responsibly is
very very critical so for instance for
an essay that I was doing with my
students
um I let them brainstorm make outlines
using conmigo a lot of my students
struggle with counter arguments I said
if you want to debate with conmigo and
find a counter argument go for it in the
last webinar I actually shared a story
about how one of my students wanted to
write a paper on the likelihood of
future nuclear warfare which I know
nothing about I I what was I going to be
able to do to help Jimmy with that paper
right but he was I literally have read
through hours of chat history of his
this summer just amazed at the kinds of
questions that he was able to ask
because he was given permission to do so
so they do need that freedom a little
bit
I love that Madeline so much more so
much better to face the world that's
coming than to stick our heads in the
sand I gotta tell you listening to speak
Madeline I'm getting ready to move my
family to Hobart Indiana because I want
you teaching my kids
um okay I think we're gonna roll the
dice again a little bit here
um and do another caller so Sheree
Nelson if you are a game for it we're
going to give you the opportunity to
turn on your microphone
um and feel free to join us on KSAL chat
with Sal
hey Dr Sheree Nelson I teach economics
at Purdue Global University cool and I I
um I am the course lead for
um
microeconomics and macroeconomics so I
designed the courses and unlike some
universities what course I design every
macro and micro teacher uses so it's not
just for me so so that being said what's
been really interesting is that
um I have uh integrated Khan uh Academy
videos into my courses before and now
I'm just doing it even more it's just
great but with
um I'll be honest I don't know much
about conmigo but I have been using chat
GPT to even generate my own discussion
board prompts and and so I tell my
students I'm using it it's okay and in
fact Purdue Global had a school-wide
meeting with all of the faculty
encouraging them to use AI but do it
responsibly so that we can learn to do
it and teach our students to take
advantage of it so what I was wondering
is
and I know I took all that time
explaining everything but I hope I gave
you a pretty good message
yeah well and also I
I'm doing things now that other course
leads haven't done yet that I want to
teach them how to do because we're a
huge university and we have a lot of
opportunity so
what I do in my classes I actually do
approach with the con the sale con
approach and that is I tell my students
if you don't have the foundation
because I've watched a an interview with
with Sal uh where you know you talk to
Sal about the if you don't have the
foundation and you're moving forward you
know basically the analogy I give to my
students is if you don't have a good
base in your house the rest that's built
upon it might fall down and and that's I
learned from sale and so I share that so
I was wondering within here's my
question I was it took me forever to get
to that just be glad I'm not your
professor
so
I was wondering is there a way or is it
already done that something is built in
with the uh uh conmigo where when you
type something in it gives you the
information you look for but it also
directs you or asks you by the way did
you know the and then ask a question
about a concept that is before that
um
like a foundational thing and yeah
yeah stab it answer that and actually
I'll try to do a little bit of show and
tell me see if I can share
a window
um and see if you made me think of that
so this is
an exercise uh this is a video on Khan
Academy on price elasticity of supply
and then I could go to conmigo and says
can you quiz me
to make sure I am ready to understand
what is in this video
that's what you were asking aren't you
like that like the prerequisite
knowledge
I love yeah yeah that's on track
question ask that question though
yeah so that's so you're right so so the
um so I think there's two layers is that
what you're describing can already be
done if someone knows to do it which as
you know most people now it could it
could it could happen through the you
know the teacher could and and we're all
doing this together I like the previous
answer around like you know we're all
learning how AI is going to be uh
absolutely yes together but I think it
could be a cool practice when teachers
are having students watch a Khan Academy
video or Khan Academy exercise you know
if the student immediately jumps into it
and they're able to engage great but
maybe if if there's already a sense that
they might struggle like hey why don't
you start with the quiz to make sure you
you're refreshed on the prerequisite
knowledge that's one way if that seems
to be something that works then yeah we
we would think about productizing that
or you know let me clear this chat
um let me make this a little bit bigger
I think my
you know we have these these these
choices of things that we think a lot of
people might ask and obviously you can
type whatever you want but maybe that's
something we can add to this
um you know help me prep with the quiz
right now that'll just quiz you on the
content of this there could be another
one just like that we add that says you
know
um make sure I'm ready for this video or
make sure I'm ready for this exercise or
something like that
um what made me think of that is I just
currently I'm just finishing up the
revision of my microeconomics course and
I'm using the new and I'm not into like
promoting a publisher at this time but
so I won't mention which one but I I am
with the new publisher who has so many
you know third-party tools for my
students and they have it so that when
you're in the book and you're reading a
concept it will it has the icon that
says you know would do you need a little
more practice with this would you like
more background you know things like
that because sometimes if they're just
looking at one concept they don't know
what concepts they're missing right
like the suggestions there oh I'm sorry
Sal no no I agree I I actually I love
this we're gonna take this to the bride
like would you like more background
obviously Academy we've always had the
exercise piece so like in theory you
could practice what you learned but this
idea of would you like more background
for it I think it's a really powerful
idea
is it okay if we borrow that idea Sheree
well you know what I have no problem
with that and in fact the new publisher
that I'm working with has also looked
through this process has said we hire
you for to be a Content controller there
you go because I have all
seen online I've been with Purdue Global
I'll have my 20-year anniversary in
October so I have a lot of online
experience and and I'll tell you I I'm
always looking to see how we can do it
better oh cool because there's there's
you can never stop improve me improving
that's right thank you so much to read
you were fantastic
thank you so much
all right so
um I think this is the great thing about
like where kamigo is headed where AI is
headed we all get a chance to write this
story just like our awesome panel's been
talking about let's get our Educators
involved let's get our students involved
we should all be driving this forward if
this is going to be a big thing for our
future now that being said we're coming
to our final 10 minutes and so I want to
end with those sort of proverbial
fireworks a chance for the panel to show
off some of their best AI skills and so
I want to tackle these two twin
questions Maria says how do I best use
AI period Scott says how can we make
this a powerful tool and so I'm curious
from Emily Kelly Sal Madeleine and Malia
are there any amazing Pro tips that you
Pioneer is that the Vanguard of this
movement can share with Educators across
the country
let's go over to Madeline
sorry if I'm doing some monopolizing I
love all of these questions and I you
know like I said I was just talking
about this yesterday with the staff at
my building
um I think one of the most powerful ways
that Khan Migo has helped me as an
educator is through
um it was something that Sal touched on
earlier expediting
uh certain tasks so I can use my time
more effectively to work on
relationships with my students
um one of the things that all English
teachers hate making more than anything
in the world is a rubric right mostly
because uh I think we are some of the
most critical of our own writing even in
those like nitty-gritty tasks so
to make a really good rubric that takes
a lot of time I've got some slides here
let me scroll to them super quick and
then I'll share my screen
um that I modeled for my my colleagues
about how you can use conmigo to make an
effective rubric in way less time than
it used to take just in terms of like
effectiveness of your plan period so I
had first told conmigo hey I'm trying to
work on making a rubric that assesses a
summative for my English 9 honors
students it gave its own suggestions for
categories but I said I wanted to make
my own that were based off of my
curriculum map
so then I made my own criteria and kind
of explained what I thought those would
look like and then conmigo asked how
many levels I would want for those
criteria
I changed the number of levels that it
suggested and then after
15 minutes of that back and forth
and then some formatting time this is
the rubric I was able to make
I did some tweaking of the phrasing a
rubric like that just to give you an
idea would normally take me about 50
minutes which is almost that entire plan
period to do and I was able to get so
many other
activities done for my classroom in that
extra time because I didn't have to
worry so hard about finding that exact
phrasing for something that
really doesn't I don't want to say it
doesn't deserve that amount of my
attention and energy but there are so
many other areas that I would rather be
spending that energy in you know I want
I want to be giving my students quality
feedback on their own writing not
spending that time drafting a rubric
myself
I love that Madeline like calling out
hey if you've got tedious parts of your
job and don't we all there's probably a
good chance that AI can take on some of
that and then B don't treat you know AI
like Google like we have for the last 20
years we just put in a question and
settle for the answer continue to push
it think of it as a dialogue the way
that Madeline did and get better and
better outputs thanks for sharing that
Madeline let's go to Kelly
foreign
so my my experiences so far with it have
been similar to Marlins as far as
proficiencies
um and both I'll talk a little bit about
how some of my students have used it too
but
um you know I wrote in the chat earlier
um when our Purdue Professor was talking
about
um using it to design some work I've
also used it to design
um an online art history class that was
brand new kind of under a time crunch
and I was like okay we gotta you know
get some creative assignments here
um it been a little while since I put
together some new things like that um on
my own so I used conmigo to help create
some projects and At Con World School we
do some cross-disciplinary work so I
even asked some questions like uh I'd
love to you know get some novel
suggestions that would also work with
um this art history unit you know this
um some of this African arter unit I'm
working on and I kind of went back and
forth with it a little while and came up
with a good interdisciplinary project
Within English with where they read
Things Fall Apart and it goes along with
some of the art history unit or
something like that so that was just one
example where it saved me a ton of time
where I think if I was just kind of
sitting in front of my screen pondering
that myself I I just would have gone
back and forth and maybe even walked
away before finishing what I was trying
to do so I had a few handful of
assignments that that really saved me a
ton of time
um and then with our students
um we have a seminar con World School
where we go over different topics every
week and sometimes we do debates or
arguments too and I had a student that
that used it to flesh out her argument
um kind of asked it to poke holes in it
or went back and forth with different
perspectives
um and she said it really prepared her
you know for the following day where she
could have done that with me but with
all your students you have time to do
that with all of your students and
um probably probably not and for us she
was also in a time zone that was nine
hours ahead of me so the chance for us
to get together before our next session
probably wouldn't have happened so she
was able to do that online I and I loved
that so she felt so much more prepared
the next day oh cool so clearly it's not
just the tedious stuff it's also the
most important stuff whether it's
designing a brand new curriculum or
helping students sort of grapple with
complex ideas that's pretty powerful
let's go next to Emily I was just going
to add I also work at conroad school and
I think the power in helping students to
ask questions is really at the Crux of
what you're what you can do with Khan
Academy I want my students to be curious
I want my students to ask questions and
I can't be there all the time to be at
the sounding board to go back and forth
but conmigo can be that and whether
they're talking about an important World
topic or a history topic or they're
working on an English essay they have
that as a constant sounding board now I
would love to be that starter to like
kind of work them through modeling
asking questions because I don't
necessarily want questions that are
instant recall kinds of responses but if
they want to ask questions about a novel
and if they want to ask questions
I know Sal has included our student
Sandy in a number of talks where you
know she she discussed uh Great Gatsby
and looking at the green light and and
had a conversation with conmigo about
that those are powerful interactions the
simulation of Jay Gatsby oh yes yes
Elation
um and
that Curiosity now Sandy she is a very
unique student she is incredibly curious
and I wish all of my students were as
curious as she is
um but teaching them that Curiosity
teaching them to ask questions and what
a powerful tool hanmigo can be to ask
questions and initiate a sort of
simulated conversation yes
love that I'll just show a little demo
as we switch to our final panelists
Malia take us home what tips do you have
for educators out there most practical
thing that all of my colleagues
this the stuff that the AI is good at it
is good at let it do that and and spend
spend your time with your students and
then I also just well I'll I'll stop
there Jeremy okay no I love that I love
that and it actually gives us two
minutes which is perfect I want to have
Sal close us off Sal you came to me in
the fall last year and said Jeremy there
is this thing that's coming out that
could change everything and I said yeah
yeah yeah Sal who knows you know people
in Silicon Valley say all sorts of crazy
stuff but now it is a reality now it's
part of our Lives what words of wisdom
do you have for educators across the
country as they finish up this beautiful
summer and then get ready to take on the
first fall with AI intact
yeah you know I'll say kind of what
we've we've been trying to tell
ourselves at Khan Academy because some
of the stuff is very exciting but it
also be intimidating it's a little bit
scary there's a lot of edge cases that
none of us know what to deal with and
the solution isn't to hide from it um
the solution is to try to engage with it
and yeah yeah you know there's all these
debates about whether AI is going to be
good for Humanity or bad for Humanity
and what I've been telling people is
like I don't think it's a flip of a coin
I actually think it's it's going to
depend on whether good people with good
intent are jumping in and trying to make
good use of it
because we know the bad people with bad
intent are already jumping in and trying
to make bad use of it so I think it's
it's actually really important for all
of us uh hopefully everyone here is you
know good people with good use cases who
want to do goodbye Humanity
um to jump in learn it ourselves don't
you know this is one of those moments
where no one is an expert and everyone
can be an expert if if you've played
with conmigo or chat GPT for an hour
you're already in like the top 10
percent of humanity right like you
already an expert so this is a moment
where people should jump in
um but also don't judge
all of generative AI based on chat GPT
which is not designed for it for this
and it's obvious in any way shape or
form
um but give tools like conmigo shot if
we can hopefully get you access
um start playing with it seeing how you
use it with your students give us
feedback because we are very serious
about we didn't talk about all the
guardrails about keeping it safe we
talked a little bit about the
transcripting we have a second AI that
actively notifies parents and teachers
if something is is a Miss obviously
we're thinking a lot about cheating and
things like that
um but yeah jump into it I think number
one if you just as was said if if you
start using it to start saving you from
some of your
um work that you it's not your favorite
thing to to write rubrics or or whatever
um you're going to start being an expert
and then if you start having your
students start to use it for even light
cases you're going to start learning a
lot and where else you're going to learn
a lot of we're all relatively new to
this space but it's it's all about
leaning into it um and thinking about it
boldly but responsibly
a lot of that and I'll just end with the
the words that I always told my
kindergarten students which is if you
want to learn something the best way
don't be afraid to get your hands dirty
so I think this is a chance for us all
to build something really awesome
together so here's wishing you all a
beautiful rest of the summer a great
start to the new year and we'd love to
be part of that Journey as well here's
wishing you many exciting Adventures
here's everyone